[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en esta
ocasión hablaremos sobre los pases
sanitarios que se están implementando e
implementando en varios países del mundo
y cómo afectarán estos a la movilidad y
a las libertades ciudadanas para ello
nos acompaña desde la ciudad de nueva
york anna céspedes ella es directora
general de operaciones de javi la
iniciativa internacional de la vacuna
contra el sida gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 la unión
europea implementó el uso del
certificado digital para poder moverse
con más libertades entre países
comunitarios además de esto varias
naciones han ampliado el uso de este
como requisito para entrar a ciertos
establecimientos como por ejemplo para
participar en actividades o viajar en
transporte público cree que esta sea una
tendencia a nivel mundial
sí bueno muchas gracias raúl por
invitarme a estar con vosotros sí creo
simplemente raúl que esta va a ser una
tendencia mundial porque necesitamos
certificar de una manera fiable y con
calidad que estamos en unas condiciones
que no estamos poniendo en riesgo a
otros oa nosotros mismos que nos hemos
vacunado es decir que estamos vacunados
que hemos pasado a un test que demuestra
que tenemos un pcr negativo o que hemos
pasado la enfermedad y estamos
protegiéndonos y esto va a ser muy
importante para salir de esta crisis y
la más increíble como en sólo una
inyección está la solución a muchos
problemas aunque se complique la
enfermedad le quiero preguntar también
si con estas medidas restrictivas son
buenos incentivos para que la población
se termine de vacunar
raúl esto como una medida restrictiva lo
veo como una medida facilitadora para
empezar tener este documento que tenía
mucho tiempo está aquí la tarjeta
amarilla lo que está criticando que está
vacunado ahora tenemos un código qr
electrónico que certifica de calidad no
puede ser una de una manera no se puede
adulterar no se puede utilizar de manera
fraudulenta yo creo que los incentivos a
la vacunación que son muy importantes
raúl requieren que nos sigan contando lo
importante que es para todos estar
vacunados se han infectado ya 200
millones de personas en el mundo ya han
muerto 4,3 millones de personas nos
tienen que explicar que la vacunación
sigue siendo muy importante y esto lo
veo como una medida facilitadora pero
desde luego no la única
completamente de acuerdo contigo por
entonces te quiero preguntar anna porque
se mantiene un escepticismo tan alto
entre la población de múltiples países
ante estas vacunas y cómo poder superar
esto y creer en que realmente ayuda a
superar esta enfermedad
efectivamente es una pregunta excelente
en raúl cuando miramos a eeuu llevamos
semanas en el 50% de las personas
vacunadas meses casi que no avanzamos de
manera radical y sin embargo otros
países aun por mucho menos escepticismo
no tienen dosis suficiente para vacunar
más yo creo que un gran problema aparte
además de la resistencia que
determinadas personas puedan tener a
inyecciones por ejemplo por eso
necesitamos vacunas que sean
intranasales y que no requieran una
inyección pero además se ha politizado
demasiado la vacuna y hay gente que
tiene escepticismo y piensa bueno una
vacuna aprobada en un año cuanto antes
llevaba diez años quizás no es segura
voy a esperarme un poco yo creo que hay
que reforzar se han aprobado en un año
porque se han puesto muchísimos
esfuerzos públicos privados recursos una
colaboración de autoridades reguladoras
y las vacunas son seguras
creo que la politización y de alguna
manera que los resultados de las vacunas
nos comuniquen políticos y no
científicos no nos está ayudando a
transmitir que esto es una intervención
sanitaria como pues bien medicamento
como el paracetamol o el ibuprofeno
anahí una pregunta mirando un poco al
futuro y ya la última en este segmento
este pase sanitario se verá solamente
mientras dure esta pandemia de kobe 19
es algo que podría comenzará a pedirse
contra otro tipo de enfermedades o virus
pues no lo sabemos todavía raúl yo creo
que tenemos por ejemplo el ejemplo de la
fiebre amarilla donde para viajar a
determinadas zonas endémicas tienes que
estar vacunado y esto es un requisito
que lleva años está ahogándose en
colegios hay requisitos de vacunación
certificados que los padres tenemos que
presentar a nuestros hijos esto va a
depender de si la pandemia se cronifica
o de alguna manera conseguimos
resolverla y espera estar muy conectado
a las variantes si el virus varía
demasiado vamos a tener que ir
actualizando las vacunas y si la
duración de la inmunogenicidad que
todavía no sabemos si va más allá de los
seis meses la conseguimos controlar a
los nueve un año dos años ésta va a
hacer que es de alguna manera el
certificado no sea necesario la solución
ahora entonces vacunarse gracias por su
tiempo y por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz resto
de ella ustedes también gracias por
siempre acompañarnos aquí en esta
de cinco minutos con hasta una próxima
oportunidad
[Música]